I hace octopus sucker massage you this
is a nipple sucker whoo what am I
supposed to put it that I want to be you
should wet it yeah if you want to get
away let's get wet yeah does that feel
good
oh oh yeah yeah if you're relaxing it's
really not relaxing for me though yeah
it doesn't stick I've never been so
disappointed to have a product not suck
my skin coog ow
just like a luchador mask yeah look how
little her face is get out of my face so
in Japan having a smaller face as a
symbol of beauty it looked like I'm
going to kill someone
hey gotta taking my eyeball out you look
cute though
we look like the worst superheroes it is
pulling my face back I feel it working
my cheeks my upper cheeks I feel like
compressing my head this is what botox
must feel like eyelid trainer what
problem I have with this is that it's
all in Japanese but the person on here
is a white girl
it's gonna like slice my eyeball there's
so many instruction like whoa wow what
did it do you don't know I'm scared I
can't see ya there's no pressure on this
there's no way it does anything this
just makes me sad that people are
wasting their money on this if all the
things can change no one's paying
attention to your eyelids face slimmer
mouthpiece why not make my face slimmer
it's what a sex dolls mouth looks like
one two I'm shining Jill
all oh you do that the hacker all I'm
good at this makes me think that I
really need this it's hurt my lips like
you feel like you all maybe gave me
Kylie Jenner lips just by like stressing
them out if I did this three minutes a
day for like a week I'd probably get
lockjaw
I feel like an ayah 7 today stuff that
like enforces a certain standard of
beauty makes me uncomfortable
yes.can weird what people do for beauty
I don't understand just be happy with
what you got yeah I like to be first
this is a Halloween costume all right